breaking news and job numbers have just
been released we thought we'd start with
that or we could talk about the Grammy
nominations because we are sitting here
now guys with two Grammy nominated
artists Alicia Caro obviously Karl won
last year for Best New Artist and you
just dropped the veins of growing yeah
so that's why you weren't eligible
because I we will see you at the table
next year but Sean not got to start with
you because this is your first Grammy
nomination you left the room to watch
the nominations so we couldn't see your
reaction so please tell us what you're
thinking what you thought when you heard
vane announce your name it was just
really overwhelming I have my whole team
is back there and everything it's just
amazing honestly it's like I don't
really have very many words I can say
about every moment that you've dreamed
about right like a dream about yes and
you kind of like are not expecting it to
feel so crazy and then you hear name and
actually it's a really super emotional
yes yes yes congrat Thank You Janelle
there's also your first nomination in
the best music video category for your
song pink that was a fun video yes so
many amazing women helped pull that
video together and it's just it's just
an honor to create an album that there's
just as much as it's about me it's about
a community of voices that I hear and I
see when I look out in the crowd you
know there's something going on in this
country and there are a lot of people's
voices that are pushed to the margins of
society because of who they love and
what God they choose to serve and I
wanted this album to be for them to be a
community in a church for their lives
unless you know what it's like to be a
nominee so what advice do you give them
for the road from this moment it's
amazing you guys both deserve it so much
and I mean whatever happens you deserve
to be here
I mean I don't even know what to tell
you you could give me advice
that's really know how to feel yeah no
one really yeah no one knows it's no
great you know Shawn you've got a hit
song it's called there's nothing holding
you back nothing holding me back in one
of the lyrics is you know I picture
people naked maybe that's that just puts
every that that levels everybody but we
have one more nomination Best New Artist
yeah let's see it please all right are
we doing the same thing who are the
nominees for Best New Artist all right
and here we go first nominees Chloe and
Halle Luke combs that's yeah Greta Van
Fleet her do Oliva Margo price bebe
Rexha in Georgia Smith very good what do
you think what are you thinking Zane
because you know this industry what what
are the tough categories were there any
surprises yeah I mean your missions in
your opinion I have to say yeah I mean I
think that i think the category for
album of the year is really really
strong it was great to see her and
they're obviously janelle see drake get
a nod see Casey get a nod I think
everyone looks really good in that
category I just have to say personally I
think Arianna I would like to have seen
ariana grande get recognized in some of
the bigger categories but perhaps she
gets nominated in other categories I
don't know as far as new wireless just
concerned you know it's interesting with
new artists because you would expect to
see certain artists like you know post
Malone and yeah and people who have had
huge years even cardi B but they have
this certain criteria that they stick to
and the Grammys have to stick to these
kind of rules in order to make it make
sense so I think you know according to
those rules that's a really strong
lineup and you know do leaper amazing
year
you know Margo price what incredible
talent but it's always gonna be it's
always gonna create debate I mean it's
kind of why we're all here yes and it's
and no doubt it's raging right now you
know outside of this this room as well
that's kind of what this is all about
right it's about getting people to focus
on music and talk about it and push it
forward
well the main categories have expanded
now to eight nominees instead of five
mm-hmm how significant is that to you I
think it's very significant from my
perspective because we're seeing more
music come out than ever before
we're seeing artists reach their
audience and create really significant
moments quicker than ever before look at
an artist like her what an amazing new
artist she is and to get multiple
nominees this year including album of
the year is incredible and then you know
an artist like you know juice world as
well who I'm not sure if he's you know I
really recognized this year but it had a
remarkable year very quickly so we're
seeing a lot of me you know what I think
is interesting about all three of you
that all three of you write your own
music and I just think that adds another
layer to the talent that you have which
is tell us your process and what it
means for you to write your own music
Sean everything I think that it kind of
brings you to another kind of level of
connection with the music and then when
you're recognized it means that much
more and when you perform live it means
that much more but it's fun I just
really enjoy writing music I'm sure you
guys do yeah because this album for you
that your new one is extremely personal
mmhmm yeah definitely it's the most
personal album I've ever made it's the
first album I made totally by myself on
the writing side which is a big deal for
me especially in the pop world and I
just feel like there's something way
more personal and way more connected
with yourself when you're able to like
reflect on your own feelings that much
like when you're writing with someone
you never really go as deeply as you
would if you were kind of force to get
into your own head there's so much more
risk because you're all alone
totally trust my life that's the
beautiful thing about it you know if you
look at artists that are mentioned in
these categories and beyond so many of
them have forged their own paths and
have decided to to kind of do this
irrespective of the kind of support
they're gonna get later on you know and
I think it's really interesting watching
independent and new music really come to
the surface a lot more now well for the
most part what's so inspiring and we see
this every year at the Grammys air
artists from different genres really
cheering each other on
yeah their each other happy birthday
yeah
no organic I mean talk about the respect
that you have for all the different
musicians in the field love you know so
many artists and for me it's not about
doing an album or song to be recognized
it's about again speaking from your
heart walking in your purpose and for me
it's about building communities and
these community of artists that have
been nominated despite what happens in
where it goes we have no control over
it's great to be at the event and to
show love to them and to tell them how
amazing they have been because it takes
a lot of work to do what it is we do
it's a lot of ups and downs there's a
lot of blood sweat tears anxiety
depression it's a lot that goes into
being an artist so we have to be there
to support it so glad you brought up
that word a couple times community
Janelle because the one thing that a
word that I've heard use recently about
music is the healing power of music
giving voice to people whether you feel
alone whether you feel marginalized even
they know so if you're at a good mood
it's a way to celebrate and your music
does that can I just say this to you
Shawn Mendes you were also nominated for
Best Pop Vocal album right so far that's
- yeah does it feel any different now
that you had your second Grammy
nomination thank you it is kind of hard
to process it isn't it you know when
you're doing music and you're younger
and you have these dreams and then it
comes true I often wonder what it's like
when your dreams really do come true so
now you're two-time Grammy nominee so
far I'm about there and my dreams kind
of coming true but yeah I mean it is
what you were saying that was so
important about all artists kind of be
there to support each other I find you
know sometimes even though our names are
so big what we do is very small and kind
of secluded and to be able to speak to
people who truly understand what you do
I can't count how many times we've just
talked for hours about you know what
we're doing for a living and it helps
and it's really kind of the biggest
thing ever
yes and it's also music is really
stepping up right now
so well I think that there have been
times when we would have hoped that
music and artists would have found a way
to communicate naturally to speak on the
times and there have always been artists
that have done that in a very good way
but never to it in a way that says
collective as it is now I believe that a
lot of artists of course all the things
that you know mentioned down others you
know are really taking the opportunity
to speak on there and there's a
transparency coming through a music I
think right now that's very inspiring to
young people who are realizing that you
know if you've got a voice you don't
have to use it yet don't be afraid yeah
totally normally guys when you're
nominated chances are you will be asked
to perform at the Grammys that night do
we dare go there but what that will be
like yeah my god you've got it yes I
think so too Zayn yeah I mean my I've
taken the stage before yeah I know this
moment you know I want to represent for
take the stage let you take the stage we
were all raving about you Sean before
you came we're at the time 100 dinner
and we killed and killed the audience is
right there and Sean is right there
people are like wow I wish you could
have seen I sat next to Keith Urban yeah
watched you in awe of your performance
yeah yeah we know some producers Mendes
Janelle Monae Alessia Cara and of course
Zane Lowe we're really loving location a
you can go to CBS news.com slash Grammys
right now to see the full list of Grammy
nominees did we mention Sean's got to
61st Grammy Awards will air this not
this Sunday but Sunday February 10th
right here on CBS and be sure to listen
to all the nominees and the official
Grammy playlist only on where Zane Apple
music
we will be right back
[Music]